herzlich willkommen zu meinem heutigen
video leute wir haben uns hier heute auf
die couch begeben um ein ich finde
wirklich lustiges video zu machen
wir befinden uns hier natürlich im
februar in dem an jedem verdammten tag
ein video kommt deshalb würde ich jetzt
mal dringend empfehlen den kanadischen
werden aber guckt euch erst mal an was
wir überhaupt machen weil wir vielleicht
wisst benutze ich gelegt ich mal die
face app mit der man sein eigenes
gesicht und auf das gesicht von anderen
leuten zu ändern kann und zum beispiel
die habe umkehren kann mit bart rein
machen kann oder sonstwas und ich dachte
mir heute ich benutze mal die face off
um einige bilder zu bearbeiten die ich
dann bei kinderreichen stelle und guck
mal wie ich so als komplett veränderte
mensch ankomme ich habe jetzt leider
keinen vergleichswert weil ich noch nie
selbst kinder benutzt habe aber ich bin
mir relativ sicher da wird einiges gehen
wenn der ball dann mit weißem bart
deutschland künftig schauen wir
wahrscheinlich einfach das einfach
niemand so leute ich habe jetzt mal ein
foto rausgepickt und ich habe schon ein
bisschen was vorbereitet ich zeige euch
einfach mal was ich gemacht habe auf
jeden fall sollte ich die haarfarbe
ändern und ich habe mich für diese
variante hier entschieden weil ich finde
das sieht noch relativ echt aus es geht
natürlich auch darum dass wir nicht
komplett crazy aussehen also wenn ich
mir jetzt zum beispiel hier die klasse
rheinbrücke das wir sonst heute gut aus
aber wenn es funktionieren würde dann
selbst wahrscheinlich ein bisschen zu
fake aus deshalb habe ich mich hier für
dieses getönte blond entschieden und ich
finde das könnte wirklich echt sein wenn
man es jetzt ganz genau anschaut an den
konturen und so dann vielleicht nicht
aber glaube in der regel schreiben die
leute da ebenso hin und her
wir nehmen als nächstes den hipster bat
weil das ist auch noch x mal guckt
solche an das sieht jetzt schon man
erkenntlich noch aber sieht einfach
komplett anders aus und das hat man bei
zwei weiteren fotos gemacht die zeige
ich euch jetzt auch mal die anderen
beiden fotos sind dass hier einmal so
sieht das in der bearbeiteten form aus
und dann noch eins
mit natürlich grossartig und da sieht
das so aus also ich muss schon sagen
finde die fotos sehen schon relativ gut
aus also man könnte glauben das ist echt
ist also mein bestes bild es ich würde
fast sagen dafür nehmen wir das foto das
ich gerade gemacht habe das würde ich
sagen leute nehmen wir als bestes bild
weil ich finde das sieht schon richtig
cool aus fertig aber ich kann ja noch
mehr dazu machen oder ok hier kann ich
noch ein paar sachen bearbeitet oder
nehmen wir einmal natürlich hier unser
lieblingsfoto das aus und wenn man die
jetzt so nebeneinander sieht leute man
muss schon sagen das könnte echt alles
lippis sein was schreibt einen sohn mit
in daraja ich bin sehr reich okay gut
aussehend und habe blonde haare und
einen bart ich überlege mal kurz raus
und dann schauen wir weiter ich zeig
euch gleich da bin ich wieder leute ihr
seht schon hier macht 21 selbstständig
universität zu köln
gucken sie mal meine biografie an das
sind die drei fotos die ich online habe
ist dass hier zug wäre zu groß sein muss
wie das install so aus meinem fall ich
bin mag es 190 bissige flughafen
sportwissenschaften
ihr habt einfach mal das so gestaltet
wie ich glaube glauben würde dass es
auch thema gut ankommen und dann noch
eine prise einerseits realität und
bild.de gibt es das wort wahrscheinlich
nicht ganz so schön und bitte keine
möbel dann kann nämlich jeder der
helpuper markt mit ansprachen und sagt
so darf man accounts wollten wir durch
die bilder also das erste chakuza muss
ich sagen das zweite geht auch fit dass
sie irgendwie ein bisschen da ist der
bart nicht so heiß geworden und das
dritte ist auch korrekt ihnen vielleicht
geht es auch nur mir so weil ich das
selbst bin und ich mich anders kenne
aber irgendwie sieht es auch komisch
auch ich ziehe jetzt einfach mal alle
leute rüber so gut wie alle leute bei
manchen kann kriege ich auch nicht übers
herz
ich habe kein altes rad ist eingestellt
ich kriege auch leute seid ihr 31 sind
ja und jetzt ab geht die post
die nehmen wir mit 63 kilometer entfernt
aber ist ja ich schreibe ihnen den die
können auch meinen weg in berlin wohnen
leider existiert die person ja so nicht
ja komm her damit
und es hat er gerade einfach wirklich
eine ich habe mich schon weggewischt ein
foto im holocaust memorial in berlin
weit hin da drin gut spaß beiseite das
warum warum machen wenn schon so was
also kann man behinderter sein okay dass
ich habe jetzt ein bisschen bundesweit
und ganz vielen leuten herzen gegeben
das heißt als nächstes heißt es abwarten
wir schauen ob irgendwelche leute ich
glaube erst mal match bestätigen dann
kann ich die ansprachen ob sie dann auch
noch antworten aber das werden wir an
einem anderen tag sehen okay heute kurz
zwischenstand das ist 20 uhr 53 am
ersten tag hatte schon max reger das ist
ganz klar deine bilder kommentiert
klebte diese bitte dass wir einfach so
leute die sache ist ich habe auch
aggressiv aber ich kann es euch jetzt
leider nicht alles zeigen ich habe eins
zwei drei vier fünf matches und davon
hatte und dazu zusätzlich haben wir
schon zwei schnitt angeschrieben ich
selbst habe gar nicht beschrieben
das heißt vielleicht wird das was ich
bin aber gespannt ob die einfach nur so
aus spaß machen oder ob die durch
glauben dass das das echt das weiß sie
schon recht verkauf so leute sind aber
tage vergangen genau zu sein zwei ich
habe mit einigen leuten geschrieben
ich habe insgesamt 15 matches bekommen
ich habe aber auch intensiv gezeigt weil
keine ahnung wie ist das schön lustig
auf kinder und ich habe auch mit allen
matches geschrieben beziehungsweise
einer hat nicht geantwortet habe ich
habe mit allen geschrieben wollen wir
mal sehen ob es den leuten aufgefallen
ist oder ob die recht geglaubt haben
dass nicht das bin ich muss ehrlich
sagen die bilder
ich glaube ich selbst hätte es nicht
geglaubt aber ich bin auch sehr
misstrauisch im internet also ich glaube
immer erst mal das alles fähig ist und
die erste nachricht hier in ihrer beiden
spielen gab dass sie aus dem norden
kommt
nun bist du denn aus dem urlaub
[Musik]
so können wir die nächste nachricht wird
in ihrer bio so verschiedene erotik
kombination stehen gab dann hab ich hier
so geschickt bei hintern haben
geschrieben hat dass sie nie das habe
ich auch nichtraucher bin in der
kombination sie schreibt direkt da ist
die eine frage stellen ich hab natürlich
geantwortet klar am besten nur mit dem
audis und sie schreibt auch du deine
youtube karriere nicht und wie man sich
als kind bekommt sich die haare blond zu
bearbeiten nächste antwort ich habe dann
irgendwann mir gedacht kommen du musst
die leute mit irgendwelchen quatsch
nachrichten haben schreiben die die
ladies lebe ich habe eine stimme ich dir
da durchwegs guten studiert
sportwissenschaften nicht eigentlich an
der spoho und ihr müsst wissen die spur
ist die sport hochschule und ich habe ja
sportwissenschaften an der uni quellen
angegeben das war vielleicht nicht so
ganz schlau aber sie ist auch die
einzige gewesen der ist aufgefallen ist
und ich habe natürlich beschrieben wir
jetzt auch gut hast du beweise dafür
wenn meine sehr sämtliche freunde wieder
studieren da meine ich ja dann seht ihr
held alle falsch und dann hat sie mit
einiger zeit dazwischen geantwortet ich
glaube es auch weißt du eigentlich dass
identitätsdiebstahl und bilder cloud
ziemlich illegal ist die hat natürlich
auch die checks dass das jemand anders
ist auf den bilder beziehungsweise dass
die person so nicht existiert natürlich
wäre und ich wünsche euch und habt es
aufgelöst aber sie war dann am ende voll
cool damit den match mit einer treffer
fortgeschrieben das treffen und kennen
sie haben wir auch tatsächlich darauf
geantwortet um 3 uhr notiert sie ich
glaube dass auch der einzige zeitpunkt
zu dem man mit seinem gewissen
vereinbaren kann auch so eine nachricht
zu antworten geschrieben was kennt wir
denn aber darauf habe ich bisher nicht
mehr geantwortet die nächste kandidatin
bestand auf einen ihrer fotos vor einer
dunstabzugshaube und dann habe ich
natürlich das richtige getan hat
beschrieben von welcher marke ist eine
dunstabzugshaube meine ist vom netz
und abzubauen
[Musik]
ja ich habe geschrieben meine ist von
aeg und da waren natürlich klar dass die
frau fürs leben beschrieben vielleicht
kein gold digger oder so schon sehr
attraktiv habt ihr noch aufgelöst dass
ich eigentlich gar nicht so aussehe aber
doch hat sie nicht mehr reagiert
wahrscheinlich hatte sie einfach keinen
bock auf gold digger nächster zeit mit
antonia ich habe schon mal kommst du aus
köln wenn du magst können wir gemeinsam
einen riegel verspeisen weil ich habe
gehört dass das alte wird ihnen gut
ankommt bei frauen und war es halt
einfach mal versucht werden hier nicht
geantwortet natürlich gegen abgehoben
bis morgen 13 uhr warte ich noch dankbar
spalte ich ihn auch wieder keine antwort
ja ich geschrieben das franchiseportal
hatte recht machen nicht youtube
aber das war ein lustiger nachrichten
verlaub wer noch lustiger gewesen wenn
sie auch geantwortet hätte aber naja die
nicht angeschrieben habe ich ihm so
scheint eine frau von großer ehre zu
sein wie geht's dir von sie hat auch
geantwortet hat beschrieben wie kommst
du denn darauf gut und dir meine ich ja
stellen dritten welt hat halt alles drin
mit snapshot wittert keinen goldenen
schmetterling und deinen kopf die
gesellen sich nur zu frauen von ihrem
mir geht es auch gut was freilich so
darauf auch wieder keine antwort mehr
leute irgendwie also ich muss sagen ich
war wirklich sehr überrascht wie viele
leute von den matches mir überhaupt
geantwortet haben weil ich habe ja nicht
nur komische bilder drehen sondern ich
habe auch vor dem quatsch geschrieben
was soll ich sonst nur so standard so
hallo wie geht's dir und dann
so beschreibt von mission gewusst ich
nächster chat ich habe ja bei uns stehen
keine möbel dass mich keiner modell an
spielen wird und sie schreibe was sind
denn möbel leute es geht natürlich
überhaupt nicht diese nachricht schicken
mehr menschen die nicht wissen was wir
sind sind mobil machen jetzt schon -
punkte gesammelt wird halb so wild kann
es ja nicht wissen weil ich wollte dann
auch nicht so sein dass all ihre potter
film gesehen
ich glaub ich glaube nicht alle jetzt
weiß ich auch wieder was muckel sind
dann wird das vielleicht doch noch was
wollte ein glück hat schon panik und
darauf hatte ich da nicht mehr
geantwortet habe dann auch aufgelöst und
sie war auch cool damit ich muss sagen
die meisten leute waren echt
überraschend cool damit das was ich da
geschrieben habe und auch nicht so aus
deshalb musste anna schön dass ich bis
weihnachten ihren fotos stehen ja
trading und candace today irgendwie
sowas wie ich habe es gar nicht gecheckt
haben darauf bezug genommen habe
schrieben sie wir kleine zu data morgens
erneuert hat man sie also bist du neue
jahre alt weil eine 20 kerzen verteilt
den urlaubstag an dem tag und sie das
foto gemacht hast wahrscheinlich um mich
raus wenn ja ist dir das so jungkamp
aufgelöst dann hast du wieder
geantwortet und hatte daher okay aber am
ende des tages kann es auch lustig also
was lernen wir aus diesem video erstmal
immer vorsichtig sein wenn ich
irgendjemanden sehe ich in dem fall war
ich meine person war ist selbst war aber
immer ganz genau hingucken weil die
technischen möglichkeiten heutzutage
sind sehr ausgeprägt und dementsprechend
noch mehr aufpassen mit dem mannschaft
im internet ich bin wirklich sehr
positiv überrascht gewesen wie gut das
funktioniert hat so viele leute
verantwortet haben und wie cool drauf
fahren wenn er wollte dann schreibt das
jetzt in die kommentare last gerne ein
leichter das video wir müssen auch wenn
ihr mit steigen aufnehmen sonst was wir
sehen sie beim nächsten mal wieder bis
dahin und macht's gut